I do wanna mention while Joey's pulling out the first name that, uh, yeah, I, I,
this is my hidden animate list.
So I actually have one from when I was a teenager that I never made public and
people would always ask me for my animate list.
So I actually made a Miami list on the Seadog VA and just put like Bocchino.
Pico is like a 10 and then every now and then I got a comment on it being like,
I hate you. Can't.
Hi. Yeah, my, my username as well. I mean, I've done a video on it already,
so people know, but it's like, my username is not even the anime man.
It was a blast for me. It was the username I used before. I was the anime man.
Zinger. What are you a big boy? Where did that go? Oh,
because my son is busy. And is it like big bang theory now?
Bazinga bet. He's never heard that one.
Never heard of that one Bible Christ.
You just mean the like fingering of that for the first one is, Oh, it's me.
All right. Fantastic. Right. Let's check out the zingers. Okay.
So first thing I got to ask is how,
when was the last time you remember updating this? Cause like, like,
I'm going to say this now. We're all picking up our mouse.
I haven't updated my mouse in years. Okay. I'll give you, I'll give you an idea.
All right. I'm looking at my watching list right now.
And a book in a hero academia. Second season is on you. You've got,
you've got a.
31 Days here and that was like, well, 34 years ago.
Now I've already finished that one though. That's like, well,
how long ago was that kind of 91 days? No.
When did season two of my hero come out? Like two years ago? Two years ago.
It was two years ago. No, it wasn't two minutes.
It was like three guys realized that boomers
four years ago, four years ago. So it's been that long since I've updated it.
Right. Okay. So wait, wait. You're telling me,
you've watched my hero academia season one. I think she's won. Yeah. However,
you've like, never talked about this before.
Cause it was like the most successful,
but you you'd normally milk that for all it's worth. You're like,
yo it's mid bro. I'm triggering all the little weaves on there. Good.
But also it's like, I don't know. To me like calling Mike,
your academia med is just as much of a popular opinion as saying that it's a 10
out of 10, the first thing that pops out, somebody on base,
but you gave it a seven out of 10. It's all right.
It was good.
It wasn't like the second coming of Jesus that people got the wrong guy.
The first thing that pops out to me here, right?
The first thing that pops out to me here as, as like,
this is how I know Joey's is my brethren here. Right. Because as we all know,
my,
I started as the animal's own and my very first anime zone
review was bleach. Yeah.
Which I gave a seven.
I can see that Mr. Joey, the anime man, or let's say
a seven out of 10. I mean,
despite the fact how much we've on fleet and unlike the professional career
look, look, look, when I, when I on bleach, right? I mean, granted,
I've never really like publicly on bleach all that much. Right?
Like I didn't make like a enemies on a review on blue tray, but look,
the only thing it's three points off for the Eisenach and then everything else
was perfect. You know what I mean? Like that's, I mean, I w I mean,
I would argue everything off is so sole society. I mean, you can, like,
you can like the.
The Aaron car or whatever. Of course.
The wake up window walk was fine as well. It was fine.
I watched all red bleed. Really. You don't, you don't need to.
And if you do just read or watch up to Saul society, which is the first doc,
which is whatever.
But you can't just stop if you're like, really?
You can't just though you want to start to see it go down.
I mean, I mean, it's, it depends like, because bleach.
Well, didn't go out with a bang. It just, it just like kind of fizzle towel,
all like reviews of bleach.
For some reason I've watched like every eyepatch Wolfe video on it and I'm like,
yeah, cool. This sounds good. Sounds good.
Don't get me wrong. It was back in the day when it was serializing,
it was a super solid show in, in Mongo. And like, you know,
as much as I like to think that I'm like, Oh, you know,
I like all the underground, like weird non-mainstream. Yeah. I love my show.
And then, and bleach was one of them, like all society Oak was on, honestly,
to this day.
I think bleach is one of just the coolest animation to come out.
Like it Def definitely. I like.
Out of the big three, which is like one piece narrative and bleach.
Bleach was just like that cool kid.
You know what I mean? It always seemed like the edgiest one.
It was definitely the edgiest. Yeah.
Have you seen what Cooper tighter? It looks like, it looks like.
AMVs, there's always Lincoln park.
I mean, that was pretty much.
Bleach. Yeah. But it wasn't like, it went better with like bleach.
Cause they had like half.
Bowls and. I don't know what's going on with this dude.
Like the powers was sick. It was just, it was just the solar pals of steak.
Then like, I want to see some mobile guys got damaged by Kubo,
but like he, he has a good fashion sense. Oh yeah.
The way he dressed the characters, they would, they just always looked cool.
The group was clean. He wasn't perfect way to decide characters.
The drip was clean, like say what you want about bleach. They had those carrots.
I wouldn't go as far as to say that bleach might be maybe not the first,
but definitely one of the biggest shows that kind of gave like, I dunno,
I don't know. Maybe it's streetwear and animals like collaborations.
I would argue, maybe came from bleach because a lot of the characters,
especially in like the title, um, channels that he wrote during the manga,
like he gave them such cool, looking straight,
but honestly you can see people wearing like this is to see.
Why go drip. Goku exists.
Bleeds is the reason like,
[inaudible], I'll show you, but like it's
, it's this meme of like Goku, like in the b-boy stance wearing this drip.
A big beam right down. I don't know why this is a meme.
I try to explain it to some people. And they're like, but why is it to me?
And I'm like, I don't know.
But the droop is clean. What is going back to drag them?
Fans? What is dragon ball memes, man, this darn Twitter. I don't know.
It's just like drip, drip coat.
And then Virgina wearing like the Supreme light sweater.
As always as being like it's clean.
Go cook on drift. Apparently that's trooper. Um,
there would be no drip Gokey without drip bleach.
If it wasn't for bleach, that'd be nice. I feel like every kind.
Of draggable meme under the sun has just been like.
Every cancerous meme and like literally cancerous.
In terms of the dragon bowl. Um, communities get lost for words.
I'm surprised. You've never seen it. It's all over Twitter.